je ressens leur angoisse du lendemain
des millions de français qui peinent de
plus en plus à joindre les deux bouts
ces mots prononcés par valérie pécresse
le jour de sa victoire à la primaire des
républicains était supposé planter le
décor mais deux mois plus tard force est
de constater que valérie pécresse a du
mal à convaincre cette classe de la
population au coude à coude dans les
sondages avec eric zemmour et marine le
pen la candidate républicaine séduit
pour le moment un électorat plutôt aisée
dans les intentions de vote du premier
tour 10 % des employés et 8 % des
ouvriers voteraient pour elle quand ils
sont respectivement 22 et 34 % à dire
vouloir voter pour marine le pen il y a
longtemps que les classes populaires ont
quitté la droite c'est donc totalement
exogènes à valérie pécresse même s'il a
réussi à contester l'hégémonie du front
national aujourd'hui est reine nicolas
sarkozy non plus n'était pas arrivé en
tête sur ce segment et pourtant ce n'est
pas faute d'essayer dès son premier
discours valérie pécresse promet une
hausse de 10 % de tous les salaires nets
allant jusqu'à 2,2 smic et entend rendre
compétitive l'industrie en inde et
bureaucratise ans et en baissant les
charges ainsi que les impôts de
production une des mesures choc de son
programme qui n'a pas fait long feu en
effet face à la grogne du patronat
valérie pécresse a dû revoir les
fondations de cette mesure l'objectif
reste le même mais les modalités sont
difficilement compréhensibles pour le
moment malgré sa valérie pécresse
continue de tenter par tous les moyens
d'attirer l'attention de cet électorat
hormis le pouvoir d'achat elle parle de
droits de succession de handicap de
famille et de ruralité pour montrer l
quelle est la candidate de tous les
français mais chassez le naturel il
revient au galop dire qu'une
consultation de médecine générale jeter
de choquer oui une consultation des ti
général à 25 euros contenu 2d prix delà
du coût de la vie aujourd'hui
c'est pas digne voilà c'est pas digne
parce que ça vaut beaucoup plus que ça
une consultation donc moi je pense qu'il
faudra travailler sur la nouvelle
nouvelle convention pour revoir le tarif
est le faire passer de 25 à 30 euros
mais au-delà de ça évidemment ça veut
dire que toute la grille change ça veut
dire que il faut revaloriser la médecine
de spécialité ça veut dire qu'il faut
revaloriser aussi les actes techniques à
l'hôpital le coût de la vie pour un
médecin n'est pas le même que pour un
ouvrier c'est bien là tout le problème
de ce genre de déclarations être en
campagne c'est évidemment essayer de
satisfaire un maximum de monde sauf que
valérie pécresse incarne aujourd'hui
malgré elle un vote de classe l'exécutif
n'a d'ailleurs pas manqué de le signaler
une bonne candidate pour versailles mais
pas pour tourcoing déclaré gérald
darmanin alors pour contrer cette image
de bourgeoise francilienne la candidate
heller sillonnent le terrain et louzai à
la rencontre des agriculteurs
ajaccio pour affirmer son côté
régionaliste charleville mézières dans
les ardennes pour parler pouvoir d'achat
aux classes populaires ou encore oyonnax
pour convaincre les jeunes de se rallier
à son discours on hésite entre eux elle
marine le pen eric zemmour on voudrait
de la fermeté qu'elle soit un peu plus
charismatiques peut-être il lui manque
un petit quelque chose se démarquer
s'affirmer par rapport aux autres c'est
bien là tout l'objectif des prochains
mois de campagne de valérie pécresse
elle qui a essuyé cette semaine les
premières critiques de son propre camp
contre une campagne jugée pas assez
transgressive accélère le rythme et le
temps est compté